You know that feeling when you finish
a sweater, you try it on,
and something just feels off?
Maybe the fit isn't quite right.
The finishing could be better.
You could have chosen a different yarn,
or it just doesn't look as
polished as you imagined.
That's where next-level
knitting techniques come in.
It's not just about following a pattern.
It's about making smart choices so your
sweaters will turn out
exactly how you want them.
In In this video, I'll show you advanced
strategies to take your sweaters
from homemade to handcrafted and polished.
And to help you plan with confidence,
grab your free printable
Sweater Planning worksheet.
The link is below.
And if you want even more control over
your designs, Knit It Now's dynamic
patterns are the perfect tool.
These aren't just your standard patterns.
They're fully-adjustable blueprints
that work for both simple sweaters
and the most advanced designs.
You choose the the size, the style,
and the details,
and the pattern updates instantly.
Let's dive in.
Fit is everything when it comes
to knitting sweaters, and the best
way to get it right, don't Guess.
Measure something you love.
Find a sweater that fits well.
Lay it flat and measure the sleeve and the
body length, so it's just right for you.
The width of the bust in the waist
and the hem for a comfortable fit.
The neckline shape and the
depth to match your style.
When you use real measurements,
instead of guessing,
you'll avoid surprises and get
the sweater that fits the way you want.
Want to take it even further?
With Knit It Now's dynamic patterns,
you can plug in these exact measurements
and create a custom pattern just for you.
No struggling with standard sizes
or trying to make adjustments later.
Your blueprint is built
to fit from the start.
To make this step even easier,
download the Sweater Planning worksheet
and use it to map out your next
project before you start knitting.
Now, once you've got the basics down,
why not have some fun with texture?
Cables, tuck stitch, lace, these details
make your sweater uniquely yours.
And here's the best part.
Knit It Now's dynamic patterns work
with any stitch pattern you choose.
Whether you want to add cables to a simple
pullover or experiment with textured
panels, you can modify your pattern
instantly to accommodate your design.
Not sure where to start?
We've got tutorials inside Knit It Now
to help you experiment with textures
and stitch patterns that take
your knitting to the next level.
I bet you've discovered one of the biggest
advantages of machine knitting.
Colorwork is so much faster.
Hand Some knitters have to carry multiple
yarns, twist them at the back,
and carefully position every stitch.
But with a knitting machine, ferrile,
intarsia, and stripes
knit up in record time.
If you've never tried
colorwork, start simple.
Maybe a two-color ferrile
design or some bold stripes.
Then work up to more intricate patterns.
Now, if your machine has a punch card or
electronics, let the machine
do the work for you.
And guess what?
You can integrate color work
into any Knit It Now stitch pattern.
Adjust the shaping,
build the pattern to your size,
and add your chosen stitch pattern.
There's no complicated math
or modifications needed.
Knit It Now has resources to help you set
up your machine and troubleshoot common
issues so you can dive
into color work with confidence.
A beautifully knit sweater can still It
will be a disappointment
if it's not finished well.
Blocking sets your stitches
and makes everything look polished.
Take time to finish neatly
for clean professional seams.
Use decorative bind-offs and cast-ons
or decorative hems
for that final perfect touch.
Finishing isn't just the last step.
It's what makes your sweater look
intentional and not just thrown together.
Do you want to take your
sweater knitting even further?
Knit It Now is here to help.
Looking for colorwork inspiration,
we've got tutorials to get you started
along with our Stitch Pattern Library.
Want to improve your finishing techniques?
We cover everything
from seaming to blocking.
Need guidance on building
your skills step by step?
Our Our success path and our skill
builders walk you through projects
designed to help you grow
as a machine knitter.
And don't forget, Knit It Now's dynamic
patterns give you complete control over
your design, your fit, and your style.
So whether you're knitting a simple
sweater or an advanced design,
you can customize your pattern
and get knitting faster.
With the right tools and support,
you can confidently knit
sweaters you'll be proud to wear.
You've got this.
With With these advanced techniques,
you can knit sweaters that are
more than just wearable.
They'll be your favorite sweaters to wear.
Now, before you go,
don't forget to download your
free Sweater Planning worksheet.
It's a great tool to help you
plan and knit with Confidence.
Get your copy now in the link below.
I hope to see you in the next
and the final video in this series,
where we'll bring it all together and show
you how Knit It Now can continue
to support you on your knitting journey.
Happy knitting.